maybe time yes a tourist trap and it's
funny because I had been wanting to do
this this is actually one of the first
movies that I wrote down like in our
initial brainstorming session about what
we were gonna do and then we had
somebody on YouTube be like oh you
should do tourist trap I'm like yeah
yeah it's on the list and then I think
he's like commented like two more times
like still waiting for that and I'm like
yesterday I was like okay I was like
okay if we can find it yeah cuz I don't
we don't like we don't own it no so I
said you know we'll watch it and we'll
do it you can see you can see a pretty
bad transfer of it on YouTube that's
what we were yeah a couple yeah a couple
people have put it out we both we both
seen it a couple times but I've seen
yeah and actually if you want to read I
did kind of like a funny breakdown of it
that's pretty long probably two years
ago now on my blog goddess of hellfire
so if it's just goddess of hellfire calm
and just search tourist trap you'll find
it but I wrote a big long thing about it
now it the thing about tourist trap is
that I think I first heard of it when
one of my favorite books when I was
growing up was Stephen King's Danse
Macabre his nonfiction you know it's his
time together talking about horror like
throughout in entertainment and I read
that book I still have it but it just
it's falling apart I've read it so many
times all the pages fell out and he
actually mentioned tourist trap in there
as one of his favorite underrated movies
from the 70s yeah so I actually started
out like sometime in the mid to late 80s
it was on cable a lot yeah in the 80s
this is this is the one where this is
one of the ones where I was a little kid
and my babysitter Kimmy who is look just
like Princess Leia if you just crashed
on her I know I've heard this she would
take me to the to the Matt matinee with
some of her friends you know little
teenage girls and I saw the the trailer
for this yeah and the trailer scared the
crap out of me man is gonna show me the
screaming man mannequin heads and stuff
yeah really scared me but I never got to
see the movie back in those days
actually first time I saw it was
recently yeah a couple years ago he's
good movie I do feel like this is one of
those ones where you know I did see it
back in the
but I do feel like if you had seen it
when it first came out or when you were
a little kid yeah it was probably like
super creepy because it really does have
a lot of really effective creepy yeah
visuals in it the movie for some reason
kind of reminds me of another movie
called funhouse yeah it is about the
same kind of vibe about that level Chuck
Connors and it's weird this is one of
the weirdest roles he's ever been in I
really liked him in this I think he was
he wasn't actually the first choice I
think they wanted their first choice was
actually Jack Palance yeah about the
same but he's dead now and then their
second choice was gig young he also said
no show Chuck Connors was their third
choice okay wah-wah but he said yes but
actually I really really liked him in
this because weird
I liked him because you could buy him as
just a nice folksy old dude yeah and you
could buy him as like a creepy weirdo oh
yeah like he came across as like very
sympathetic but also kind of threatening
yeah I liked the movie it was crying it
kind of reminded me of like like I said
funhouse yeah out there with like maybe
motel huh hell memory I'll tell hell
that like that about this weird guy who
lives in a house almost kind of like
this almost kind of like in psycho
yeah and he has a house and his fill of
mannequins and yeah they're like an
assembler more a mer animatronic yeah
he's turning people into mannequins yeah
and then you find out that the
mannequins can move and you're not
really sure why but I think what they're
talking about is you know that he has
psychokinesis that's what that's what it
seemed like whoa
yeah and that I think that's one of the
best things about this movie is that it
really has kind of a weird I mean it's a
pretty weird premise when you think
about it on the surface it seems like
it's gonna be your standard slasher
flick there's like all these kind of you
know teenager 20-something college
students they're going on a vacation
they get a flat tire and then they end
up having to go to this out-of-the-way
yeah tourist trap it's a wax museum but
it's mannequins and to get help with the
car and everything and then they start
getting bumped off one by one but the
way that it's filmed and kind of a lot
of the set pieces it's kind of different
and even though yeah there's a killer
and he wears a mask and there's all
these creepy mannequins and stuff but I
think the psychokinesis angle yeah it's
pretty nice that's kind of unheard of
well not really unheard of but it's it's
a rare component of this type of movie
yeah what they're talking about
basically is almost like a poltergeist
episode yeah well and that's what the
the opening scene where the first guy
woody he's going you know you he went
off to get the time one of his higher
effects and he finds this sort of
abandoned gas station or service station
or whatever and he goes in the back room
and like all this [ __ ] starts flying out
there's mannequins pop out and they're
laughing and so it's a really creepy
scene yeah and we were talking about how
cool it was because it was filmed in
like broad daylight it's not that
nighttime or anything but it's still
really unsettling because this is kind
of the first scene of the movie yeah and
they don't explain anything yeah they're
like what's going on is it a ghost is it
a booby trap what is it they don't
really explain it and then they just
followed the rest of the kids while
they're looking for woody and find in
this other yeah it's pretty weird man
you know you got a guy who's I guess
he's a poltergeist focus and he's crazy
he's a killer and these mannequins kind
of carry out his old fantasies they
carry out his whims
it's weird I guess in through
psychokinesis yeah you know it's almost
kind of like if you can do that then
what is easy kind of like a Sith Lord
proud of out of starch out of Star Wars
like a crazy Sith or what is he you know
they never really explain it he's kind
of like found the Opera in a bit yeah
where he has he wears a mask over his
face yeah he looks a little bit like
Phantom of the Opera cross with leather
face yeah like it's that kind of luck
yeah he's got multiple personality
disorder yeah and it's pretty neat and
towards the end I mean as characters get
turned into mannequins the one surviving
chick I don't know if I'm gonna spoil
the end of it she tries to escape with
all the mannequins and she does she
escaped with all the mannequins in her
car
so are the mannequins also kind of
possessed by the spirits of the victims
that or did she just think that that was
a situation I don't know they kind of
leave that vague honestly I think the
initial is funny because I think from
what I've read on the Wikipedia page the
initial conception of the story did not
have the sec
kinetic angle okay but this was produced
by Charles bands who also produce he
produce from Ray animator and a bunch of
other yeah you know the big full moon
production or whatever it was called our
Empire pictures yeah so you produced a
lot of those kind of horror comedies and
stuff you know and he directed some as
well even directed this one this was a
guy named David shmeller although John
Carpenter was the first choice to direct
this I would have loved this as a
carpenter flick but I think it might
have been good you know it kind of fits
into there if the transfer quality that
we saw was better it would probably kind
of fit right in with a car yeah I would
like to see it on better transfer
because I've only seen it like on VHS
quality yeah it would be nice if there
was a blu-ray release yeah maybe there
is like there very well may be because
yeah because so much of this movie has
to do with the whole atmosphere yeah I
mean like I said it's like a slasher but
it's not gory really I don't think
really think there's no nor in it it did
have some good seventies atmosphere but
they also delivered it showed those
mannequins moving and it showed some
people you know tied up and captive and
you know so it wasn't all atmosphere
like some of the 70s movies right did it
did deliver on the promises but yeah I
think the coolest thing like I said they
don't explain how this guy has these
powers huh I thought the implication was
no they don't say this in the movie I
don't think I thought the implication
was that he was kind of capturing these
people's souls sort of okay well I
didn't like putting them that maybe that
made the mannequin which is that that
may well he was claiming that yeah
wasn't it yeah I don't know if that was
actually happening Oh does it matter
yeah you know that's I kind that was
kind of what I took away from it I
thought I thought he had psychokinesis
and he believed he was it could have
been Souls enter and that maybe the girl
who survived thought the same thing also
you know but he was tripping he was
obviously insane yeah so but I don't
know maybe I'm sure but maybe he really
could do it but you know you can move a
mannequin with your mind many of them he
was animating the mannequins yeah pretty
much and he was maybe them like
following people and attack people in
their opening and shoot people and stuff
and one of the coolest things I think
once some of the best
you know he can make him talk - yeah
that's right they make funny noises and
weird yeah like and he could make them
he could do other people's voices like
he could make other people's voices come
out of them yeah because a couple of
times when people were looking for their
friends he'd be like hey chasing that
one girl through the woods knee through
the head of that mannequin and it landed
on the ground remember was jaws open and
trying to bite her weird that was really
I think that was the creepiest part of
the movie for me was those mannequins I
mean the things are always creepy but
then like the mannequin would slowly
turn its head and then its jaw would
drop open and I'd be like that he's
really creepy yeah so I'm kind of remind
me of that mannequin from saw
yeah the mouth is yeah kind of puppet
marionette looking man yeah yeah yeah
someone look like real mannequins like
out of a department store and some of
them did yeah it's not like that
James Bond movie - dead silence with the
with the ventriloquist no yeah I don't
know man ventriloquist dummies and
mannequins it's always like creepy
because they look like people but
they're not people yeah you got that
like uncanny valley thing going it
wasn't really clear to me whether or not
the body of the victim was in the
mannequin or not well okay I'm not
really sure because there was one scene
I don't know if you were in the bathroom
at this point but there was one scene
where the killer he had two of the
protagonists he had them tied up and
they were watching him kill this girl
that he had kidnapped earlier yeah and
she was like laying on the table and he
was like putting like plaster all over
her face yeah but I don't make a mold
yeah I don't think he was putting her
inside the mannequin a noise I'm making
a mold they would say what he did with
the body so yeah I don't know what he
did with the bodies I don't know if he
buried them someplace or anyone but yeah
he just because they showed him you know
faking a mold of her face and then later
he was like painting it and he's like so
pretty you know would you like that
creepy creepy voice yeah you get a weird
voice who's making yeah you said it kind
of sounded like I can't really do it but
it sounded like kind of uppity a murmur
a little bit creepy yeah a little bit
like Sling Blade yeah
this is slightly like sleep all we know
is no call was the boy's name I think
what happened yeah what was that guy's
name from Slingblade I can't remember
now it might've been it might have been
out of it but yeah he's kind of sided
like that and another thing too other
than the visual of the mannequins yeah
the best thing about this I mean some of
the musical choices that they made were
a little strange well really only at the
beginning because yeah they happy yeah
have that happy soundtrack yeah like at
the beginning of the movie I was like
dude yeah kind of song and sounds like
this can't be the right movie yeah but
then as it goes on but one of the
coolest things is when they have those
scenes with the mannequins like when
when the girl like the final girl when
she's like trapped in the room with the
mannequins and there and it's dark and
they're all like turn their heads and
their jaws are dropping open and then
there's that weird it's not really music
it's always going oh yeah yeah coming
out of their mouths like coming out of
their mouths like almost like they're
talking or singing or something it is
like super creepy I just think that was
really really well done
I'm gonna try to find a donut blue-ray
yeah it would probably get better yes
you know it's a good movie but I feel
like it needs to be visually appreciated
all yeah because it has so much cool
yeah the visual Atmos do Youtube version
at the you - yes like a VHS pretty damn
crappy yeah it's basically I that's the
only way I've ever seen this movie yeah
because you know I probably saw in the
eighties on VHS yeah they might they
probably have a TV I would think it's I
had perceived that it was kind of a cult
classic right and even though I met I
didn't see it at the time but like I
said Stephen King you know it was his
recommendation yeah talked about in
there like how spooky and Atmospheric it
was so I later sought it out because I'm
sure it's like I said I loved that book
and I was trying to read a bit it's
weirder than the fog and creeks oh yeah
wait weirder than the fog I wish it
looked as good as the fog does now like
that might blue my blu-ray steelbook
edition of the fog looks looks gorgeous
yeah I'd love to see it this movie
looked that good
yeah no now I'm curious - we probably
should have looked it up for and
recorded this and see if they're
actually historic but I you know it's it
definitely is some
it needs that I got a feeling there is
no blu-ray release for this yeah it's
too obscure check right now I don't know
how obscure I think it is but okay so
actually we did just check we did just
check and there is a blu-ray release I
did you can get it from wall buck
Walmart for like 12 bucks I'll probably
get that yeah I like to see that on
blu-ray damn look at this turns trap
blu-ray for disc limited collector's
edition oh okay holy crap okay so I was
wrong there is a blu-ray release yeah
like I said I was pretty sure that it
got it didn't do that great when it came
out that says cult classic now yeah it
came out in 1979 I don't know if I
mentioned that or not but uh yeah as it
went into a heavy rotation on cable so a
lot of people saw it so I think it kind
of you know bubbled under is sort of
like a sleeper hit that actually would
do very well on cable because there
isn't a lot of gore in it but it is
scary it's creepy yeah so that would be
something that they would show a lot
back yeah you could actually get away
with that because I don't really
back in the 80s remember when we were
kids you know on Showtime there couldn't
be that much gore in it yeah they had
some but some of the real gory stuff
they they never played it and I don't
remember seeing it well anything I mean
I saw some boring stuff on there but not
you know not like Cannibal Holocaust
yeah right we're not gonna share that
Italian levels of gore
Jane's levels of [ __ ] it's early in the
morning we don't we don't usually record
these in the morning but I got woke up
at like 7:00 a.m. kind of Thank You
Kitty and kind of cuz I didn't feel
again so I just said yeah what the hell
I work I'm gonna go ride my fuel and he
wants to go ride his fuel today so he's
like well let's just do the movie review
I'm like even though it's 8:30 I'm
finished a single cup of coffee yeah
yeah sounds like all like yeah but yeah
so I can recommend the movie it's a good
movie yeah if you really if you like
atmospheric 70s horror like I said not a
lot of gore I don't there there's a lot
of action though no nudity no there's
implied nudists seven
hotties yeah you don't like hot sauce
hot halter-top types and how does that
how they did two tops no bras but yeah
you know so actually liked the the main
girl that played Molly the dirty the
brunette the no no no the blonde oh yeah
urgent yeah it felt sorry for mr.
Slauson what's the name of the guy yeah
look at the strap the brunette looked
like one of the girls stuff with
Charlie's Angels that was you know me
that was I think that was Tanya Roberts
okay and she was it was bugging me the
whole time
but she was in the Beastmaster okay and
she was in Buick L okay beast man beat
actually if you know Achilles good good
bond movie Beastmaster theme song yeah
Beastmaster was movie was was done by
the guy who did phantasm remember yeah
that's right same guy but I think that's
where when I was watching tourist trap
I'm like yeah Tanya Roberts it's like
man what do I know her from and speeds
faster okay yeah I recognize her from
Vsauce earlier but I think the main girl
that I didn't like that movie I
recognize her from but the main girl
that was in it that played Molly she I
don't remember seeing her in anything
else I think her name was
Jocelyn Jones she was actually pretty
good in this I liked that she was you
know like most final girls in the horror
movies of that era yeah she's gonna be
like I'm the one that doesn't want to do
anything and I've heard a square and we
shouldn't skinny dick yeah it's like a
trope yeah it was yeah that was very
common and she kind of took it further
than most you know she kind of but you
know she was a Republican outfit yeah
little braids but she she got like Swiss
Miss now that I think of it from the
little Coco package yeah but yeah so she
was and she was the only one that felt
sorry for him yeah it was nice to like
the other ones weren't mean to him but
they were you know they were kind of
like hey red flag this guy seems like a
weirdo but she was like no he's just
lovely and right yeah which he was but
also it was crazy
yeah yeah it was really good and like I
said if you if you like
atmospheric 70s horror like we do don't
expect a lot of gore don't expect nudity
or anything like that but it's kind of
spooky ghostly kind of like the perfect
cult movie because it's like a slasher
but not and the premise is kind of
strange they don't really explain like I
said with the telekinesis they don't
explain it really they're just like well
here it is it's not as atmospheric and
slow as changeling though no it does it
yeah it's not as I feel like the
changeling is more like a prestige like
this we did have action in it yeah oh I
probably put it on par with like I said
you know fun house or yeah I feel like
Tobey a person yeah yeah about like that
it's kind of back more action I would
say than the fog actually yeah I
definitely think it was pretty good but
yeah if seriously if you're creeped out
by mannequins or anything when speaking
of which so I think somebody else
recommended this too and this was a
movie I had forgotten about that we need
to do magic yeah yeah it's been a long
time so that was a creepy ass play also
yeah we should do a whole ventriloquist
dummies will do devil doll that one
wasn't that good I saw it on that
Mystery Science Theater but yeah we
Jenni and I can recommend this one it's
a good movie yeah we're finally getting
around to it yeah and I think I'm gonna
get the blu-ray yeah this definitely
needs to be something I'm gonna put that
in my collection for discs what the
hell's all that stuff there must be a
lot of extra shadow that was a regular
release had four discs well the blue
right now it was eliminated as a limited
edition how much was that did you see no
I didn't see how much that was I saw one
on from the Walmart thing that was like
12 bucks it's worth 12 bucks I'm not
gonna spend $40 on a four well no it's
not that good if I was a freak on it but
you know I want to buy the new Dagon
release that's coming out - yeah it
wasn't this month I think it's July July
same month as my birthday yeah yeah my
first July 1st that's your birthday but
yeah so you know check this one out you
can watch it for free on youtube if you
want to see the deluxe version you can
buy it on blu-ray
I'd actually probably
blu-ray I have if I had to do it over
again
watching it for the first time I would
think I'd like to see the blu-ray
release probably be a better impression
of the movie because the the YouTube the
transfer is so bad it looks pretty damn
crappy yeah yeah you had to be kind of
patient with it yeah I'm watching it
spoiled very spoiled like we got so used
to me when I was like when I was growing
up it didn't really I didn't matter
that's because I did you know I would
take movies up Cinemax or whatever just
watch them over and over that like look
like [ __ ] look like [ __ ] but now you
know the surround sound and HD and big
green you can see everyone's pores ya
know it's like you're just looking out
the window yeah yeah you're not looking
at this street you're looking out the
window but it's time to be alive yeah we
made it we made it this far I'm gonna
keep on trucking until they invent
something where I could plot my brain
into it yeah cyborg body and then they
just gonna live forever
yeah download our consciousness into
like a into a Cyberman from [ __ ]
Doctor Who yeah I'm totally down for
that yeah alright so remember if you
liked the show remember to Like share
subscribe if you'd like to financially
support the show you and good to our
patreon page which is patreon.com slash
13 o'clock or you can go to our blog
which is 13 o'clock podcast
wordpress.com and there's a link in the
sidebar to a PayPal account also one of
our fans has started a subreddit for our
show oh yeah I forgot to mention that
yeah we'll probably mention this on the
main stage show but yeah so if you want
to go over there it's just called 13
o'clock podcast he's putting up the pot
he's putting up the episodes one at a
time so I think like the first 10 or 15
or fans yeah I wouldn't have even
thought of that so you guys like share
subscribe share our stuff it really
helps us out yeah yeah and remember to
tune in for our regular episodes every
Tuesday and our movie reviews every
Friday and that will do it for today's
installment see you later